[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
francia enfocó su cita con la actualidad
francesa por las pantallas de france 24
que realizamos especialmente desde el
departamento del río dron en el sudeste
de francia en esta entrega viajamos al
pueblo de la mundo están aquí un grupo
de emprendedores ha puesto en marcha un
novedoso sistema de agricultura basado
en lakua pone a conversamos también con
la organización tendrían tierra de
vínculos sobre la difícil situación del
campo francés donde día a día disminuyen
el número de tierras explotadas pero
también el número de explotaciones
agrícolas y finalmente conocimos
distintos ejemplos de producción más
sostenible del codiciado pero también
polémico manjar francés louis foie gras
bienvenidos la trama es el departamento
que más produce agricultura vivo en
francia sin embargo está lejos del mar
los creadores de la granja integral
quisieron aportar proteínas animales a
la dieta local y para eso se dedicaron a
la piscicultura y a lo que no esperaban
era encontrarse con una gran cantidad de
hierbas hortalizas y verduras estas
historias
la agricultura en la granja integral no
funciona como la conocemos hasta ahora
en esta oscura cámara está el corazón de
la explotación
en dos piscinas crecen desde hace cuatro
meses varios miles de luciopercas un
pescado de carne blanca
lucas el criador usa apenas una linterna
frontal para alimentarlos limpiar las
piscinas en una rutina que no debe tener
fallas
está oscuro al interior porque este
pescado es muy estresado así que
limitamos la intensidad luminosa en las
piscinas para que reduzca su estrés se
alimente mejor y no se enfermen en el de
cappa de maravilla
aceites y harinas de etiqueta roja la
mejor calidad en el menú de estos peces
hay que cuidarlos bien pues a diferencia
de un sistema de piscicultura
tradicional aquí los desechos orgánicos
que los peces vierten al agua tienen un
rol fundamental
los pescados van a cargar el agua de
nitrógeno y amoniaco luego haremos pasar
esos desechos por un filtro biológico
que va a transformar el amoníaco el
nitrito y el nitrito en nitrato que es
muy buen fertilizante para las plantas
una vez que el proceso está hecho lo
enviamos a ese gran estanque para luego
enviarlo a las plantas a quien les sirve
de fertilizante un filtro
de las hortalizas y hierbas se encarga a
lohan formada en agua ponia en nueva
zelanda
sabes desde algo más chicos tenemos
desde hierbas aromáticas como el
cilantro la albahaca menta a la sal un
poco de perejil y si no legumbres de
hojas como acelgas espinacas paxson o
col china y lechuga tablets disciplina
nosotros tenemos un sistema de piscinas
con balsa que flotan entonces hay
algunas verduras que son menos propicias
que otras por ejemplo los tubérculos
como estarían metidos en el agua no
funcionan la papa por ejemplo no es
ideal
una vez que los almácigos tienen hojas y
raíz están listos para ir al agua
sed banner oye a la west-eastern a esta
válvula está conectada a la gran
cisterna que recupera el agua del
sistema de piscinas
si yo abro el agua sale y las plantas
hacen crecer sus raíces directamente en
el agua esto es cilantro vemos las
raíces muy desarrolladas si es tan
blancas quiere decir que la planta tiene
buena salida sin sombras y que la planta
también siente
la granja intenta hacer una agricultura
lo más natural posible lo único
artificial es la calefacción del
invernadero que permite alargar las
temporadas y acelerar el crecimiento de
las plantas la luz en natural por lo que
las verduras siguen siendo de estación
pese a ello sus productos no caen en la
categoría europea de agricultura bio
el reglamento bio europeo no reconoce
como agricultura violó que no ha crecido
en la tierra pero nosotros usamos
semillas bio y no tratadas si debemos
atacar las plagas usamos productos
biológicos y no usamos fertilizantes
químicos las plantas en otras de los
desechos de los peces y no con
fertilizantes químicos como la
hidroponía clásica
félix dirige un restaurante en un pueblo
vecino
apenas la granja estuvo lista quiso
probar sus productos
donde ellos compramos estas pequeñas
lechugas por ejemplo que utilizamos para
hacer un snack con mantequilla le
compramos también mezclen cilantro
lechuga japonesa pequeñas hierbas para
darle un valor agregado al plato y
aportar gusto volumen y decoración antes
comprábamos a distintos agricultores
pero con el frío y el invierno es cada
vez más complicado conseguir las hierbas
las hierbas muy bonitas que duran mucho
guardarlas largo tiempo es lo mejor esto
nos facilita demás la vida porque no hay
tierra en las hierbas nos evita la fase
de limpieza así que además ganamos
tiempo
el restaurante de félix no es
vegetariano pero privilegia las verduras
en sus platos
la presencia de la granja es para él una
buena noticia como lo es también para
curiosos vecinos que dos veces por
semana aprovechan las ventas a la granja
que organiza el equipo
venimos a conocer estamos completamente
a favor de tener verduras y pescados
cerca de casa sin tratamiento químico es
importante en estos días comer sano la
granja integral se instala en una zona
que produce agricultura desde hace años
nuestro vecino produce a campo abierto
tomate hay pinos y una gran variedad de
verduras nosotros queremos complementar
lo que ellos hacen más que competir en
europa existe una decena de grandes
granjas como está nuestro proyecto es
instalarnos al lado de grandes ciudades
la granja espera levantar pronto otros
invernaderos y sobre todo una tienda
allí estará completo el proyecto de sus
creadores
en el reportaje de la granja integral
veíamos que esta es una alternativa para
producir hortalizas verduras e incluso
carne animal de manera responsable y en
superficies más pequeñas quizás también
es una alternativa para el campo francés
que está viendo reducidos el número de
explotaciones agrícolas y agropecuarias
para conversar sobre este tema estamos
conversando vía el director de teo de
lilian buenos días me llaman buenos días
cuéntanos justamente cuál es la
situación actual en el campo francés el
último censo agrícola hecho en francia
demuestra que hemos perdido en 10 años
más de 100.000 granjeros o campesinos en
el país y entonces eso tiene como
consecuencia una aumentación del tamaño
mediano de las explotaciones el enfoque
va hacia una agricultura muy intensiva
cuál es la causa de que haya cada vez
menos explotaciones los agricultores
están envejeciendo y que es lógico que
antes de 2030 la mitad de los campesinos
van a retirarse a jubilar vamos a tener
millones de hectáreas en francés que
iban a cambiar de propietario los
vecinos están comprando las tierras de
sus de los que se van la población
histórica del campo está con menos
interés los papás no motivan a sus hijos
y hijas a
tornarse como como agricultores pero
vemos otra gente otra generación que
está muy motivada pero el problema es
que las autoridades no impulsan no
apoyan realmente este sistema porque
nuestro tradicional no hay nada que les
impida a ellos adquirir una tierra y
explotar la es un sistema muy cerrado
hay gente que habla como de magia y si
tú no vienes del medio agrícola no
puedes saber que cualquiera se está
vendiendo y entonces es como sólo en
como algunas personas que sólo van a que
se las van a pasar etcétera también la
superficies cultivables se están
reduciendo en francia la manera de los
políticos de la gente que piensa en el
territorio es siempre construir entonces
hay como también influenciar las
residencias secundarias y en la mayoría
del tiempo son antiguas fincas en
francesa cada año perdemos la superficie
de para alimentar una ciudad de 170 mil
habitantes frente a este escenario qué
es lo que hace también la gente puede
ahorrar su dinero en nuestra
organización y con este euro vamos a
comprar quieras y luego las vamos a
alquilar con de forma protectora para el
campesino con primas que no tienen
quieras que tienen un perfil un poco
nuevo que quieren producir orgánico tras
el paso de las fiestas echamos
a la producción del fue a el codiciado
manjar el francés que se obtiene tras la
alimentación forzada de patos y de
gansos con el auge de la agricultura bio
y sostenible cada vez más personas
proponen maneras alternativas de
producirlo
sus hígados estarán pronto en el plato
del consumidor pero estos patos y gansos
han podido disfrutar durante 5 meses de
la vida al aire libre y de una
alimentación sana
es la apuesta de olivier criador y
productor de franjas que llevó el
conocimiento del sudoeste francés a
normandía en el norte de francia no
quería hacer una crianza en edificio
industrial porque encuentro que los
animales están muy concentrados una
crianza sin vacunas y sin antibióticos
dirección a la sala de alimentación para
una segunda vida más corta y
desagradable durante 13 días o libia va
a hacer engordar a la fuerza a patos y
gansos pero incluso allí el trata de ser
lo más delicado posible
al comienzo hay un estrés para ellos
tengo algunos que se ponen a volar el
primer día debo cerrar la puerta para
que no se escapen hace algunos años que
hago esto lo que falta sobre todo es no
herir los porque el animal herido sufre
y puede tener una infección y luego la
muerte por eso que en el sistema
industrial les hacen jaulas
con
otros métodos de engorde están siendo
desarrollados para reconciliar a una
parte de los consumidores con el
producto hace algunos años mientras
investigaba sobre la diabetes este
científico encontré una técnica que
consiste en introducir bacterias en las
especies recién nacidas
tenemos aquí unas bacterias intestinales
que van a servir para colonizar los
pájaros al momento de nacer e intuir un
crecimiento espontáneo y natural del
hígado enriquecido en grasa
una granja experimental ha sido
instalada en aller para desarrollar el
método y orientarse hacia un producto
ético destinado al mercado de lujo otra
técnica nacida en españa se basa en una
alimentación de los animales
particularmente calórica pero el
problema es que la ley francesa solo
entrega a la denominación a los
productos que se obtienen con la
alimentación forzada estos métodos
alternativos no convencen a los
defensores de los animales el que su
alimento
cualquiera sea el método para obtener un
hígado graso el método busca generar una
enfermedad en el animal usted puede
hacerlo de manera más o menos mala pero
no vamos a decir que hay algún método
que sea aceptable para ellos
ya invito a que acepta agrupa sino la
última alternativa es el foca o falso
graso una pasta vegetal aromatizada que
recuerda al gusto del foie gras
y hasta aquí este capítulo de francia-
enfocó muchas gracias por su compañía y
hasta la próxima en las pantallas de
france 24 y en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
[Música]